hello everyone we are back at the
Kashima memorial it's round seven and
it's a matchup everyone's been waiting
for
they are good friends even better rivals
it's a world champion Magnus Carlsen
versus onigiri who is not having the
greatest tournament so far and now he
gets the black pieces against the world
champion you know a lot of life could be
better but everyone's already seeing a
lot of nice things about this game it's
I've seen it it's really impressive but
I'm gonna let you decide if it's if it's
really that impressive so without
further ado let's just check it out
Magnus after six rounds sharing the lead
with Serbia Carrick and so let's see
let's see how it goes across and opens
with c4 the English opening and Guerra
replies with E 5 we have Knight to c3
Knight to f6 Knight to f3 and the knight
to c6 the 4 nice variation of the
English and the g3 Causton prepares to
fianchetto the light square bishop we
have d5 gary attacks in the center we
have C captures Knight captures and just
Bishop to G - Gary develops the Bishop
Bishop c5 prepares the castle both
players now castle with castles castles
and just d3 we have h6 by Gary and now
Knight captures on d5 Queen captures on
d5 and just a3 now preparing before
there are no good discoveries with the
knight so for the moment there's no way
a good way to take advantage of this
very nice a well x-raying of the bishop
towards the queen with a 5 by Gary
preventing before and not just the ship
to be preparing to develop this bishop
to this very nice diagonal from where
the bishop will hopefully be able to
harass the King we have but sorry Queen
to east six just getting the Queen out
of this nasty diagonal and also the the
the point is now
d5 phone is now further defended we've
looked the c1 attacking the bishop and
now Queen to e7 you could move the
bishop but Gary also wants to develop
the Bishop to e6 so first Queen t7
guarding the bishop and now the light
square bishop can also be developed we
have Bishop the c3 now getting the
bishop to the desired the diagonal and
Knight the d4 by Geary
we have III offering a trade on f3 gear
except with night captures Queen
captures on f3 and now just Bishop the
back to d6 and here cousin devises a
brutal plan here he plays Queen to h5
and okay yeah if you can play a Queen to
h5 your opponent doesn't have any
Knights well you don't have any nice
yourself but you do have a very nice
bishop on c3 and if you can get your
hooks into the game somehow for a moment
it seems like it will not be that easy
to bring the rooks into the game but
across and finds a way here here it goes
c6 and now the move that really
impressed everyone it's the move that
well basically this is the move that
made the game what it is here across
some plays f4 okay first you don't think
it's anything impressive but after Geary
captured he captures on f4 here the
normal replied the engines favorite
reply and just you know the common sense
reply is ecaptions on f4 just getting
rid of your weak pawn you will have a
nice opponent eye for your blocking your
opponents the bishop are you're probably
gonna bring this rook over to e 1 and
it's just gonna be a very nice position
for white but here it seems that Carson
is running out of fuel to the trot with
Gary with on Twitter and he plays G
captures on f4 and it's a really
impressive move because it invites Gary
to capture on e3 a3 with check and
that's something you just I don't know
it's just a very impressive idea so Gary
decides the captured we have Queen
captures on e3 a with check King to h1
and now a really delicate position
Gary plays rook to d8 there is also the
possibility of going f6 just blocking
Carlson's very strong Bishop and now
after the variation Bishop to c4 with to
the plan Queen g6 to h7 this is how you
prevent it first Queen to h3 you offer a
trade of Queens Queen to g6 and now
Bishop to g4 you actually allow this
Queen to h7 and after this check King to
f7 Bishop to g6 check King to e6
now comes looked the e1 check and now
King to d7 and
seems you were able to escape Queen
captures and g7 with check King to c8
and it's a real long king walk but it
actually works for black but who in
their right mind would go for something
like this so again it's one of those
positions where it's actually okay to
play f6 but here Gary wants for rook to
d8 and Carlsen just continues with his
attack we have looked he won of course
there's no point in further capturing of
the pawns we have Queen to c5 Gary now
wants to trade Queens and of course
causing the client we have f5 stifling
the development of Gary's LightSquared
Bishop and also now a lot of roof lifts
are possible so here what do you do
again it's a very delicate position if
you play a slow move like Bishop to d7
then cousin had in mind Bishop captures
on g7 King captures and now f6 with
check King moves and now Queen captures
on h6 threatening checkmate
and after butcher blocks let's say
Bishop to f8 you will just move the
Queen and now there's really whatever
black plays you're just gonna make a
nice rook lift and win the game there's
there's no defense here from blacks
perspective so after f5 giver
immediately rushes back with the bishop
with Bishop to f8 guarding g7 so no
Bishop captures and g7 is it possible
but now just bishop the e4 strengthening
the f5 pawn and seeing what Geary will
play and again f6 now doesn't work
because now you can capture on f6 with
the Bishop Bishop captures and now after
G captures on f6 now you have the open G
file Ruby you want check after mitchell
blocks you can even capture it the King
captures and not just Queen g6 check
King f8 Queen captures and have sex with
check King to e8 and now a nice
discovery Bishop captures on c6 will be
checkmate so a really really poisonous
position and the giri has to be very
careful what he's doing here and of
course I do too this is wasting a lot of
time so here look the d5 Gary tries to
offer the rook at least to prevent her
cousins attack for a little bit but
Carson isn't interested in this here he
goes rook to f3 not rook to G 1 root 2 G
1 would be would be premature as you
would allow Bishop captures on fi
and after for example Queen captures on
h6 you don't have a good attack because
Bishop captures on e4 with check D
captures and now you can block the
bishop would rip the d4 and well it's a
black black survives that's the point so
here after this rook to d5 Carson isn't
interested in that here goes
rook to f3 this rook is still keeping an
eye on the f5 pawn and the rook the g1
is now gonna be played Gary first place
rook to b5 sorry b5 and now comes Luke
to g1 we have looked to a7 trying to
bring the other group to help out with
the defense and now capturing on h6
would be a terrible mistake if you
capture then of course you see how black
counters this yes you cannot capture
because the pawn is pinned but you just
unpin it Queen characters on g1 and well
the black will be up a whole rook so you
have to be very careful here cross and
place Bishop to f6 and it's a beautiful
it's just a nice bone for Geary to play
with I mean what do you do here no
crossings not interested in this giri
the shop ok helping out with the defense
the light square bishop not doing all
that much the rook sort of in the game
but not really how do you how do you
proceed here it's very hard to do it to
decide what to do here of course you
cannot capture anything the point is
still pinned so here Gary plays g6 and
here is a well the very critical moment
in the game I'll give you a couple of
seconds feel free to pause the video and
try to find it the best idea for white
here
for those who were able to do it
congratulations you are an extremely
precise player and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show the move
Karlsson played is Queen to h3 but the
quickest way is actually to just grab on
g6 right away because now after pawn
captures and Queen captures but yes
black will block with the rook rook g7
but now you get bunch of characters on
g7 and now whatever black plays white it
just wins if you go and capture the
bishop now then you just get rook to g3
threatening checkmate and after the
Queen blocks now it's just Bishop
captures with Czech pawn captures and
now f6 and you will of course win back
even more material you are left with a
completely winning endgame on the other
hand there is this Queen to c1 check but
it's not a problem if black doesn't
capture but rather goes Queen c1 check
you can go King g2 this is the move you
had to find probably the one Carson
wasn't interested in looking for and
then after Queen g5 the only move that
allows black to continue this game will
leave you up a piece just captures
captures and after Bishop captures
captures not even needing to capture
here you could also capture on g7 and
not just f6 check King moves Bishop
captures here you are not up a piece but
you are up the exchange you are up two
points and it's a completely winning
endgame for white so it's really curious
why Carlsen didn't go for rook captures
and g6 but it's a move 25 gear it was
very long time perhaps he didn't want to
allow gear eat.i time to think during
call since thinking time so okay here
Carlson goes back for a moment we have
Queen to h3 and now just work the d6
getting the rook out of harm's way and
also threatening to capture the bishop
now cost and defense it again Queen to
h4 and now
giver decides to give back to give up
the exchange we have rook captures on f6
Queen captures on f6 and now rush up to
e7 forcing the Queen to move but now
just Queen captures on c6 cross and
decides okay I've attacked enough it's
time to trade down into a completely
winning endgame and Geary Geary trades
with Queen captures Bishop captures and
now just came to g7f captures with
captures and not d4 cousin has a past
bond he decides to push it of course
with a4 and now comes even d5 we have b4
by black and now cross and goes just
bishop teh threatening rook to e7 check
but also rook captures on g6
so here Bishop to g5 blocking this if
you put g5 then h4 is an option but here
after Bishop g5 h4 just as well Bishop
captures doesn't really matter what you
do with rook captures and g6 with check
King goes to h7 and now look back to c6
with an attack against the bishop Theory
played Bishop to g4 would an attack
against cousin the rook rook to f4 was
played now both of the bishops are under
attack and here rook to g7 has been
played and it was in this position
unmoved 39 that onigiri did not resigned
but he lost on time now but it's just as
well I mean whatever you play doesn't
really matter you could go a cat person
before now we have to pass pawns you can
pretty much choose which one you want
push completely winning endgame there's
nothing black can do here but yeah
really really an impressive game by
Magnus Carlsen I mean really really
crush the giri there and that I mean how
do you how do you decide to play it's a
I he must have had a very nice rest day
2 days ago I've seen on Twitter he did
play some football as he usually does
but here after this f-4e captures and
now not he captures but rather G
captures this is this is this is real
chess this is very impressive and well
this is what we all enjoy and especially
when you see the world champion plays a
move like instead of this G captures and
I for allowing this or almighty
a check it's just super impressive
so yeah extremely well deserved the
victory for Magnus Carlsen and I will
show the standings now so for those of
you who haven't seen it you know close
your ears or eyes here it is
sorry about that nope not that but this
there you have it all of the other games
have been drawn so here after seven runs
cross and again in the sole lead with
five points after
onigiri with four and a half points only
person said a hurricane then with three
and a half a lot of people Viswanathan
Anand still in third now in Navarra
Dingley Ron Alexander Grichuk Veselin
Topalov and the team order a job of and
then which two and a half points Sharma
media roof and onigiri who is having the
worst tournament
well maybe ever since he became an elite
player in last place with two points but
yeah I mean it's just things will happen
so you know everyone can have a bad
tournament it's and it's not a problem
but yeah that after that rook to g7
onigiri lost in time and just a very
very impressive game so yeah I mean what
do you think about the game is it is it
really what everyone is saying that it's
I wouldn't call it like the best game of
the year or anything like that so far
it's a very impressive game but that
just that decision to play G captures an
F for really takes takes it to a whole
new level so I'm very happy that this
game even happened and and I hope you
are too
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would also like to present
you with a position for you to solve
it's a position from a game I played
today it's a tournament game I played
against the French and I had this
position so it's a it's a very nice
position I was able to win it and there
is a tactical line here that wins for
white so if you're interested I also
feel free to pause the video and try to
solve it if you will comment on it then
just right it's the bonus position the
the solution is this but you know it's
it's a really really an intense position
so I was very happy I handled it
properly but yeah well like I said
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Joshua green rod
buzz better get Robert Palmer holy Boyd
and Roberts Kieffer for conversion to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content checking up on what's what in
the world
continuing the capo Blanca saga and of
course as usual checking up on your
suggestions thank you all and I will see
you soon
have an excellent rest of your Sunday